a store go to c-span org slash cities
tour professor and political activist
Lawrence Lessig is next on book TV the
former Democratic presidential candidate
talks about his reasons for running
campaign finance and more
on behalf of the Safra Center for Ethics
at Harvard and the Harvard Law School
Library I would like to welcome you to
this one of a series of book talks my
name is Jonathan Zittrain I direct the
library here and teach cyber law and MA
some time and current colleague of
Larry's and in a spiritual sense student
of his but this isn't just a book talk
although it is that about Republic lost
2.0 even more lost is the title still in
the desert but in between Republic lost
1.0 and Republic lost 2.0 a very
intriguing thing happened my colleague
Larry Lessig ran for president of the
United States of America
[Music]
between this group and the listeners of
c-span we may have a majority of
Americans already on board I also want
to welcome our friends from c-span who
are recording this and that's a chance
to alert you that anything you say or do
will be broadcast and in rerun
indefinitely but it's amazing you ran
for president there I did I did do that
that's right and so the inartful way of
asking the follow-up would be what are
you thinking but the more artful way of
asking it would be how did you come to
the place where you said you know what I
think I'm going to run for president
well as you know Jonathan you are
responsible for that I'm because of
course we had long conversations about
this decision before I made it and what
I laid out to Jonathan was a sense which
is not uncommon especially I guess among
the people who are here that we are at a
point in our the arc of the history of
our democracy maybe on the way down
where we've got to come to recognize a
fundamental flaw has evolved or emerged
inside of our democracy I think I talked
about it during the campaign in too
abstract way I want to be very
particular that flaw is an institution
called Congress Congress is a failed
institution a failed institution and
it's crippled and corrupted by the
corrupting influence of money by the way
in which we've denied equal
representation through gerrymandering
through all the mechanisms by which this
institution no longer represents the
American people and the reality of
course of our government is we need both
Congress and the president to be able to
work together to get anything done so
what I feared as I saw this election
emerging is that we're gonna have a
typical presidential race so round one
was this I think you know this is like
June and July June and July this summer
yeah yeah as we saw this emerging
presidential race it was going to be
like every presidential race these
candidates were going to talk about
all the amazing things they were gonna
do promise the moon but the rocket can't
get off the ground and the rocket can't
get off the ground because the essential
institution to do any of the things that
they're talking about doing whether it's
dealing with climate change you're
dealing with minimum wage or dealing
with health care or dealing with student
debt any of these issues requires
Congress and so if we don't have a
campaign focused on this corrupting
influence that makes it impossible to
get anything done we weren't going to be
able to bring about the mandate the
political mandate to actually achieve
that kind of change so the conversations
that you and I had was a recognizing
that be then saying well what if we
tried to hack this process by launching
a race for president which at least had
the chance to be able to get into the
debates and present this case in a way
that might have the opportunity to shift
the direction of at least the democratic
debate to build the recognition of this
essential reform that was needed and so
the calculation was what would it take
to get to those debates and that was the
upside and then the downside of course
was everybody thinking I was insane the
incredible personal cost and pull it and
you know cost my family and all of that
I mean all the downside is there but the
one you and I had the longest
conversation was was everybody's going
to think you're insane so there was this
moment I don't know if you remember this
distinctly you left my office two
minutes later you came back and you sat
down and you said okay I've decided you
you're gonna run and I said well well
what do you mean why have you decided
there you said well because you're gonna
recognize that if the only thing holding
your back is the belief that people are
gonna think you're silly or crazy that's
never gonna be enough reason for you not
to take this risk and it was true at
that moment I kind of recognized I had
no good reason not to take this risk is
that if that was the only
potential downside so that's basically
one we decided to I would do it thank
you you're welcome
and it all went according to plan
I want to make sure we cover three
distinct areas in the roughly one hour
we have with each other plus a reception
downstairs that may have somewhat modest
or past so I don't want to cause a
stampede afterwards but you're on notice
the three areas are first a chance to
crystallize in a way for the record your
sense of the problem and the solution
and what you've even learned in the wake
of this attempt at a solution so that
analytic thing second your sense of the
mechanics of running for president and
what we all might learn from that and
what it says about the state of politics
and our democracy in 2015 and third a
chance to get some of the personal color
to it a real sense of the conversations
you have not just with me but with many
others some of the actual reactions I
think love to immerse in that a little
bit and these don't need to be three
separate things we can take them all as
we go but maybe a way into it is to say
once you decided that you wanted to do
it in part to get a message out through
the debates at the very least what's the
next set of phone calls most important
to place to try to do it I mean the
understanding we have right now is kind
of a combination of Schoolhouse Rock and
Frank Capra it's just like you find a
podium and announce your run but what
what really happened well so in late
July early August we made a series of
telephone calls some to the Democratic
people in democratic and I didn't stop
you there because this is the wonderful
candidate thing of saying we yeah does
that mean you will I've already had a
team know there's a team okay and and
they start making telephone calls to
feel out how
party would react and the person we
talked to inside of the Democratic
Committee was like geez they'd probably
welcome this like because at that stage
they were thinking how do we multiply
the number of people who might challenge
Bernie because Bernie was the biggest
threat perceived to be to Hillary so I
think they were open to the idea so the
committee basically was standing for
Hillary well they wouldn't say that and
they wouldn't acknowledge that but what
they said is they you know the signal
was that they would be open to this idea
and then at the very same time they
released this standard for getting into
the debate which was three polls at 1%
six weeks before the debate and we just
did some back of the envelope
calculations of what it would take to
get enough media to get to that place
that we could be confident to have that
support necessary to get into the debate
um and so at that with this point we
decided to go forward everything was
about what stunts could we pull to get
enough attention to get enough people
focused on this issue so that at least a
slice of them 1% would say yeah this is
the person we want to support so I can
get in so this is a substantive version
of the deez nutz theory but so this is a
good moment to say all right you had to
hone a message designed to reach low
information voters early on in the
process they're not yet even focused on
this and so let's just jump back then to
your core message we already heard a
kind of rehearsal that Congress is
broken but go one more layer on it what
was the problem and what was the fix
well the the the message that resonates
with the people as we find them most is
that money has corrupted our political
process I think that's I think that's
too simple even though I think I've
written two books that try to say
nothing more than that but I think
that's too simple but that's the message
that out of the box we wanted to hit
like everybody you know literally 90% of
Americans believe that money has
corrupted the political process
Republicans have never got so
and these aren't just straight bribes
you're seeing that's the process itself
that they focus too much of their time
on this tiny slice of the 1% were
funding elections so in the current
election cycle a hundred and fifty eight
families have given half the money
that's been contributed to the super PAC
and candidates so far that that's a
banana republic democracy that's not an
American democracy and and this is the
thing that immediately would resonate
with people that that's the issue they
wouldn't care about so so that's the
substantive issue but then you know
there's two versions of the history of
the campaign not a long campaign so it's
not going to take long to explain it but
you know what is the we had this all
figured out in advance story and the
other is we just stumbled into it in the
following way let me tell it as if we
had it all figured out in advance the
question was again how do I get out
there in a way that gets the news media
which is this completely bastardized
infrastructure today relative to when I
was a kid but anyway this thing called
cable that's right bastard yeah it's too
subtle even for us okay it's it's the
problem with it is it's you know the
attention span of cable news is you know
two or three or four minutes so so the
question is what trick can you do to
make it interesting enough for them to
want to talk and listen to you and so
you know I originally launched this in a
with a plan that when you think about it
I think makes perfect sense the plan I
wrote about in first version of that
book and the second version - which is
what I wanted to be was in effect a
referendum on this problem like a vote
for you is a vote saying this problem
has reached such a critical dimension
that nothing else can be fixed or
matters until we fix this problem right
and so we are saying we the people you
know voting for Lessing's candidate or
saying we want this issue fixed first
and if nothing else happens this is the
thing that's got to happen and and so if
I'm running as a referendum what seemed
to follow
was that once that's done I had to step
aside right so that as a matter of logic
kind of played once you were done not
winning the president's no but done
implementing basically there's a statue
you've got I don't know it's in the book
but the statue right and it's not a
secret statue you nope it's a real
statute it's not TPP its amethyst you're
referring to the trade treaty the
trans-pacific just become public right
but it's called the Citizen Equality Act
but the point is that statute is what we
would enact and once that enact was
enacted it seemed to follow from this
idea of being a referendum candidate
that I would step down and just to be
clear Congress would feel great pressure
to pass it when otherwise it absolutely
wouldn't since it would divest its
current donors of their power it would
do that because the referendum had
spoken and because they want you out it
could be I mean you know the the deep
strategy to how you would play that is
that once you got there you would act
like a crazy man
every week a new CIA secret revealed
right as quickly they would be like what
can we do to get rid of this man and and
that would be the incentive to get them
to pass the act but not just that right
it would be you know the idea was as we
described it there would be candidates
running for Congress mother an area 51
tour if you don't pass this I want to
know the real story of area 51 its son
but but the idea is what we would also
have candidates running for Congress who
would say look I'm a referendum
candidate ooh I will vote to pass this
so that so that if you raise the
significance the salience of this issue
as you know we thought the presidential
campaign would there would be enough of
a political mandate to actually force
Congress to do something which it's
almost impossible to imagine them doing
otherwise okay but the point is that
that sound that seems to entail is that
once it's done there's no reason for me
the referendum candidate to be there
anymore I would step aside that's the
way the mandate was constructed okay now
the advantage of that structure was that
first it was so weird every cable news
show wanted to talk about it but the
problem with that is that
it was so weird that every cable news
station wanted to talk about it for
exactly three minutes okay so so it's
not possible in the context of the three
minute conversation about this for
people to understand the mode of what it
would be solving why it made sense and
why it made sense them to step down
instead every time I would talk about it
we would spend half the time talking
about whoa wait you're gonna resign
you're just getting elected to resign
I mean so who's the vice president and I
would be there oh wait a minute I'm not
getting elected to resign I'm getting
elected to pass the most important
democracy legislation in 50 years no no
forget that what about the resigning
part you want to resign then right so
the point was it was very hard in the
structure of that to get them to focus
on you know the real objective of the
campaign quickly who would be the vice
president yeah I'm not gonna tell you
that there'd be a secret vice president
yes
TPP would be the vice president there
would be the this process was both um
you know helpful in the sense that got
lots of attention to the campaign but
hurtful in the sense that it didn't help
people to understand exactly how this
could work and and so this as this was
happening the number of people who knew
about the campaign's going up so the
ultimate objective of getting to the 1%
to be able to get into the debates was
being achieved but it made it harder and
harder to talk about the campaign as
something anybody could understand
because it's just something completely
different from what anybody running for
president has ever tried to do so what
happened I mean I don't think I'm saying
this was a strategy you're getting
awareness are you polling at 1% right so
here was the first totally unexpected
problem um so we were encouraged we said
we would measure the support for the
campaign by doing a kind of
extraordinary fundraising challenge that
we had to raise a million dollars in
less than 30 days um
successfully raised a million dollars
how much did you know ahead of time that
you could hit the million did you have
people ready to say you know we've got
your back no no because remember it's
you know it's set relatively small
numbers
like you could get a billionaire to say
I'll give you a million dollars you can
you have to raise it in $2,500 because
this is for the campaign not for a PAC
or some not a super PAC so you're
basically like Dr Goode and you're like
I need 1 million dollars and I will save
the Republic sort of like that yeah
that's not how I thought about it but
okay if you want to think about it like
that that's fine um so we launched that
and and we said if we got that that
would demonstrate real support for the
campaign we got to a million dollars in
less than the 30 days and it's worth
noting for the record how did it compare
to the fundraiser I was about to note
that for the record yeah um this is the
part where Larry gets passive-aggressive
for no particular reason
it said we call it a presidential
temperament yeah so the so at that point
that means that I raised more than two
maybe three at that point of the
Democratic candidate it's more than five
of the Republican candidates so we
thought in a world where money matters
so much this is the way of saying it's a
real serious campaign right and we
thought that once we were there the
Democrats would do what the Democrats
had done for every other candidate which
is to say welcome to the race Larry and
you know may the best man or woman win
right um but there was crickets from the
Democratic Party after we you know hit
the number and said I was gonna run um
and we inquired you know we said can we
talk to somebody there because you know
every time every when every other
candidate launched there's a big
announcement from the Democrats
welcoming into the race and um and so it
originally I thought well this is just
symbolic but then the polls were not
including my name in the poll so there's
this catch-22 if you have to get to 1%
in the polls but the polls aren't
including your name it's a little bit
hard to get to the one because how many
different polling outfits are there so
there's two kinds of polls basically
there's robo polls or internet polls and
interview polls and and so among those
there's probably eight polling companies
that are doing that are countable and
both you thought would count as far as
achieving three one percents know I mean
we knew it would only be the interview
only the interview poll yeah but it was
only like pee pee pee
was including my name and Republic
Policy Polling and day when they
originally included my poll at the end
of August I was qualified they found me
at 1% so that's why we thought it was
plausible but it was really hard to
fight to get the other ones to include
and so as we came to the first debate
political did this piece where they had
done the numbers it said if you'd
admitted in all the polls he would have
been at 1% but he wasn't in the poll so
he wasn't at 1% and people were you know
kind of frustrated Bloomberg did this
very powerful editorial which is you
know whatever you think about his crazy
campaign it's kind of outrageous that he
wouldn't be allowed in the debates but I
you know technically according to the
rules didn't hit the numbers for the
first debate so I was excluded from the
first debate and who did they ask about
in the polling that was done I assume
they asked about O'Malley and Webb and
Chaffey Chafee Sanders homo and mmm I'm
a whole bunch of people who are despite
the fact that their announcements had
not gotten widespread coverage their
announcements of running well Webb and
Chaffey Row I mean by Joe Biden Cuomo
didn't get you didn't hear yeah I didn't
hear about it either but apparently no
it's not great they were no way they
weren't running they were still being
pulled that's right would they have
shown up at the debates it has gotten 1%
in these polls well they're without
running you're really getting the
numbers I mean they were just you know
the poll is the question was who would
they include and their view was we got a
right to include whoever well so did you
talk to the polling people and be like
look if you're going to include Cuomo
and many people talk to the polling
people and what they say they said we
get to decide that seems somewhat
conclusory yeah well they decided so so
that was the first debate but the second
debate we were really optimistic because
we were beginning to hit the poll
numbers we're gonna do this quick cause
I don't want to talk about this part
first cuz it's like the boring part of
the story it's not the important thing
the important thing is the issue and
what we have to okay but here's the
boring part of the story so we hit we
are hitting the poll numbers Monmouth
had us at 1% Monmouth is exactly the
kind of poll that was supposed to count
NBC found us at 1% and then we got a
notice for
the my campaign manager got a call from
the Democratic Committee that said
actually the rule is not three polls
within six weeks the rule is three polls
at least six weeks before the debate
uh-huh he's like and how close was the
debate at that point two weeks away so
he lets out the help of Doctor Who
that's right and doctor who didn't
answer the phone so um at that point
when they were told that we were like
well wait a minute here's the explicit
statement of the chairman of the
Democratic Party that that's not the
rule the opposite and they said well
whatever this is the rule according to
it and it was on the basis of that when
it was clear I couldn't be in the second
debate that I had to decide whether it
made sense to continue and you know
there are a lot of people a lot of
people here who are working incredibly
hard for the campaign but I didn't think
I could ask them to continue to work if
it made no sense because there's no
chance to be in the debate so that
weekend is when I made the decision to
withdraw and then there's big uproar
because people were a little bit
frustrated that they would change the
rules midterm and exclude from the
debate and then CBS then the following
week less than 10 days before the debate
announced their version of the rules
which were different again which was now
it's not one person it's one percent
that's it's greater than one percent in
three polls not six weeks before but
five weeks crafted precisely to exclude
the third of the polls that found me at
1% within a couple hours like they said
by 12 o'clock on a certain day so a
friend of mine said well we got a little
bit of Larry Mandarin going on here and
so it was clear that you know CBS
neither would include even debate so
that's that's when the campaign ended
Wow all right so problem-solution that's
what you want to talk about yeah tell us
about it
well so analytic solution here is not
hard to figure out right so when I was
obsessing about the way campaigns were
funded I feel I now see that I was
missing a pretty important part of that
story and by campaigns you mean both
congressional and presidential campaigns
or I care about Commerce Congress and
the important part of the story that's
missing is or it's it's not recognizing
is the reason why the way we fund
campaigns is such a terrible problem
is because of the basic inequality that
it introduces into our system like this
is a representative democracy the one
idea that the idea of representative and
democracy embraces is the idea that we
are equal citizens that we are supposed
to have a democracy where we as citizens
are equal participants but where you
have a system where members of Congress
spend 30 to 70 percent of their time
raising money from the tiniest fraction
of the 1% they can't help but be more
focused and concerned with the interests
of that tiny fraction of the 1% so
that's a system where this basic
equality is denied and once you think of
sorry I was just gonna say and that is
in some ways you are saying a
comparatively new problem this is not
like it's pretty much been this way for
the past 50 or 100 years right I think
and and the book really works to say to
show this I think that the nature of
this problem has radically changed in
the last 20 years that the it's not that
money hasn't mattered money has always
mattered but the idea of members of
Congress in this you know kind of
Skinner box like existence like
constantly pecking on those telephones
to get the money they need to fund their
campaigns that psychological experience
is relatively new and and what it does
is create an institution that is
incredibly sensitive to how it can make
the funders of campaigns happy and what
that must mean given that we are not all
funders of campaigns is that they're not
as interested in how to make the
of us happening right so that's an
expression of inequality but it's not
the only expression of inequality in our
system right so think about the way
districts are gerrymandered out of 435
seats in the house maybe 90 are
competitive I mean for 538 thinks that's
about twice as many as they're
competitive but let's say 90 are
competitive which means 345 seats are
safe seats and what it means to be a
safe seat is if you're a Democratic
voter in a Republican safe seat your
congressperson doesn't give it doesn't
care at all about you because there's
you're still the politician yeah that's
right
well because because that politician
knows that your vote can never matter
that the only votes that are gonna
matter in a safe Republican seat or
republican votes
the only votes are going to matter in a
safe democratic seat are democratic
votes which means if you're the minority
in INEOS districts your votes don't
matter which means in America 89 million
Americans have effectively no
representation inside of Congress
because they are in the minority in the
end it doesn't just push the competition
into the primary where the primary then
becomes hotly contested and when it
pushes it into the primary what it does
is amplify the polarized nature of
Congress in even more because when
you're a Republican and you're only
afraid of the primary challenge what
that means is you're only afraid of the
far-right primary challenge and when
you're a Democrat and you're only afraid
of the primary challenge it means you're
only afraid of the far-left primary
challenge because those are the people
who show up to primary votes so what
this system does is that it amplifies
the polarization of America it makes it
a worse a more polarized institution
than actually America itself now just a
somewhat technical question on this
given that we have a little bit of a be
testing we've got two chambers of
Congress and one of them isn't elected
by district would you expect then to see
differences between the House and the
Senate yeah I mean
not as much because still you've got
fixed borders and manat multi-member
seats I mean the alternative to this
which is what the Citizen Equality Act
pushes is the idea of multi-member
districts which is what our framers had
we had multi-member districts for
Congress and rank-choice voting multiple
choices for voting so that means that
you could produce basically a
representative Congress and which job
but just by changing this solves the
Sophie's Choice problem this is saying
yeah you can send both kids to summer
camp ie Congress it would be the person
who wins and the runner up that would be
you basically would say five if you had
five seats you gonna elect five
representatives you get your five votes
and you rank them and and the five
people who get those would would be the
representatives but the point is
whatever the particular zuv it is we
could easily construct a system that
would be more representative which would
again address this deep inequality in
the system and then a third dimension
yes which you know is kind of the most
grotesque and ridiculous is that we
allow within our system these plainly
intentionally discriminatory burdens
like voter ID rules which which make it
impossible for harder for some people to
vote than others as the Brennan Center
determined in their view of the 2014
election it's tied directly to race so
if you are an african-american in Ohio
it's harder for you to vote than if
you're a white person in Ohio even
though you know Ohio after 2004 got
something like three billion dollars for
new voting machines in white districts
they got more voting machines and in
black districts it turns out they have
fewer voting machines right so this is a
decision I you know driven not by race
necessarily it's driven by politics
which of course correlates with race but
the point is this increasingly this
place is a burden which is again an
unfair unequal burden when you know
you've got to wait 30 minutes to vote if
you are a rich person with a nanny and
iPhone
that might not be a problem but for most
Americans that's a poll tax that you
just can't afford to pay so that's
another dimension of this inequality and
so what you know what the campaign tried
to say is look we have a corrupted
Congress crippled and corrupted it
cannot address any of the issues it
needs to address corruption is the
disease but equality would be the cure
if we could embrace a principle of
equality political equality I'm not
talking about economic equality I'm not
talking about any equality other than
political equality if we can embrace the
idea of equality inside the system that
equality would break up the mechanisms
of corruption that make it so hard for
this institution to then fund and that's
what the mechanism of the omnibus
citizens Equality Act is meant to be yes
so it's got solutions that speak to that
each of these three the way we fund
campaigns the way we gerrymandered
districts the way we suppress the votes
of people unfairly unequally yes is
addressed in the Citizen Equality Act
which was really you know we didn't
write any new statues we took these
proposals that were out there for
dealing with each of these things
separately and we just wrapped them
together and said look the principle
here is a principle as old as this
Republic even though never recognized
perfected in this Republic the principle
of equality and that principle if we
just embraced it in a representative
democracy could begin to get us back a
democracy that could be responsive to
what people cared about now it sounds
like Hillary and Bernie and perhaps the
others as well it's possibly even
helpful for them to run against Congress
as you've pointed out Congress is not
exactly very popular right now so it's
not a staking out a radical position to
point out that it's corrupted or broken
is this the kind of act they could at
least get behind if asked would you
support this act or if it arrived on
your desk would you sign it we'll see
this is one of the this is one of the
kind of deep corruptions of the process
that I didn't know clue of when I until
I got into the middle of it you know the
primary process is a process of winning
over powerful party members to support
your campaign who are those powerful
party members they are members of
Congress so if you're gonna go out there
as a candidate running for presidents in
party primaries and and be successful
with these people it's not an effective
technique to stand up there and say the
problem with American democracy is you
guys Congress right because those are
the people you're trying to win over now
you know some of those people you know
actually agree with that you know many
of them there are great leaders in
Congress who see the problem of Congress
who would say absolutely Congress has
become the broken institution in our
government but not many of them like to
think of themselves or their institution
as the broken institution American
government so it's not a great strategy
and what's striking is I you know
studied these debates that I was not
allowed to be a part of but I've studied
very carefully there is no point at
which any of those candidates ever talk
trash about Congress never say anything
about Congress and what so how about the
campaign finance system well they do but
he but this is what's frustrating even
as that issue is now us being surfaced
it's being surfaced as if the issue is
which of the presidential candidates is
virtuous and which is not as if the
problem is presidents as if we just had
a president who was not corrupted we'd
have a democracy that worked but look
you know Barack Obama didn't back away
from the public option in Obamacare
because he'd been bought off by the
insurance companies that's not what that
was about Barack Obama backed off of the
public option because Congress was in a
place that it realized it couldn't
survive Democrats couldn't survive
because of the money that would come in
and affect the elections of Congress the
corrupting institution is Congress but
even in these right now in these
Democratic debates it's everybody
speaking as if the question is who is
the virtuous one and my view is you know
it doesn't matter at the level of the
president anymore it doesn't really
matter because whether you're Hillary or
whether you're burning
the issue is going to be whether there's
a congress that can do anything for you
and that's only going to be addressed
that's only going to be achieved if we
actually direct the energy of this
campaign towards fixing this corrupting
which is why you saw a referendum
candidate McNee as the crucial element
so in the wake of what happened what's
moving this forward 2.0 look like what
does that look like yeah I mean that's
hard right I mean I mean there are
people have taken up the idea of the
Citizen Equality Act and want to
continue to build support for that as
the framing notion and I'm all in favor
of that and I encourage and support it
as much as I can but I think you know we
as citizens have to kind of step back
and recognize there's a there's a kind
of missing part to our democracy right
um you know if the president goes nuts
or starts misbehaving there's an
institution that can do something about
it Congress can impeach the president if
the Supreme Court starts going crazy
Congress can pack the court or give the
president the power to pack the court or
they can impeach the justices like
there's a way to deal with the problem
the president or the problem of the
courts but there's no mechanism in our
system for dealing with a broken
Congress Congress isn't going to fix
itself the president doesn't have an
incentive to take on Congress because if
you take on Congress you're taking on
your own party you take on your own
party you pretty much guarantee there's
nothing you're gonna get passed if you
get nothing passed you're a one-term
president so the president can't take it
on the courts not going to take it on
Congress is not going to take it on
who's gonna take it on right there's a
very unfortunate ibly the voters won't
be reached by the message that the
voters don't elect Congress the voters
elect members of Congress right and so
if you look in this politically
gerrymandered system and you said you
know voters help us overthrow this
corrupted Congress most of them live in
districts where they realize that means
they've got to vote for a Democrat or
you have to vote for a Republican and
they think these people are just as bad
whether their Democrat or a Republican
there's no reform really possible there
so it's not going to come bottom-up it's
not going to come top-down it's not
going to come from the side from the
courts there's a very you know
interesting moment to the history of the
Constitution when two days before the
Constitution's published to the American
people they the way to amend the
Constitution is exclusively through
Congress only Congress can propose and
remember the Constitution George Mason
stands up and says you know wait a
minute what if Congress is the problem
because if Congress is the problem
they're the only ones that can amend it
then we're stuck and you know it was a
kind of first time there was a Homer
Simpsons duh moment in the history of
American politics where they call it hit
their head and they said yeah that's
right and they created a convention
clause to give the states the power to
call any conventions article 5 article 5
to have a convention to propose
amendments of the Constitution that's a
mechanism but of course most Americans
are terrified about the idea of an
article five convention why not but most
of what drove you in this very room yeah
we had this conversation here that's
right yeah about the article five
convention was called the con con con
that's right
convert cut yes something like that the
Constitutional Convention conference yes
yes and if you're against it your con
con con con
but no but you know the idea that we're
gonna have an article five convention to
deal with Congress strikes most people
as kind of crit so here we are I think
you know most people see there's a
problem this is an institution that
bounces around single-digit approval
ratings
it's a bankrupt institution but what is
the solution to that problem and so as I
was pushing this idea forward of a
referendum through a referendum
candidacy and people were constantly
saying to me yeah that's crazy it's
crazy stupid idiotic you don't
understand the way below uh my constant
feelings sometimes expressed most of the
time just in the middle of the night
thinking this as I couldn't sleep was
I'm you know well what is your solution
to the problem that you know it's great
scene and Game of Thrones were Jon Snow
in response to the claim if the terrible
plan he has says yeah you're right it's
a bad plan what's your plan that was me
I went this turned out things turned out
really well for Jon Snow
oh we don't know that yet don't you know
anything so so wait a minute
is your campaign dead you'll have to
wait to the next season to know there
are microphones positioned on stands and
since c-span is indeed recording this
for you to jump in would require going
to that microphone or that microphone so
feel free to go up to it and it sounds
as if questions about the campaign
speculation about the next season of
Game of Thrones or ideas on if you
accept
Larry's version of both the problem the
potential substantive solution about
which an academic can write a book but
there's still the question of the
mechanics of doing it it'd be great to
hear about that so why don't we start
here feel free to
who you are my name is Aaron Riley and
I'm not affiliated with Harvard Law
School in any way so I'd be curious to
know why the courts can't do anything
well of course the courts could fix the
problem that gave rise to super PACs and
they should but an important part of you
know my view of the problem is that
that's not enough that's nowhere close
to enough then what we have to do is
change the way campaigns are funded and
the courts don't have the power to order
Congress to pass public funding of
campaigns it just it's not within there
Ken and the courts don't have the power
according to their jurisprudence to tell
Congress has got to change the way it's
it's drawing districts I mean it might
come to the place where it's able to
challenge districts as politically
gerrymander is inconsistent with the
Constitution but that's not enough right
so it takes real leadership and and and
this is you know part of my view of
where we liberals I think sometimes have
made a big mistake you know the history
of the last 40 years or 50 years maybe
of of liberal jurisprudence has been
whenever there's a problem let's race to
the cord and get five justices to give
us the right answer as opposed to let's
go to the American people and convince
the American people of what the right
answer is and then they get the
democratic branches to give us the right
answer well I think here it's both
because it's necessary and because it's
the only way it sticks that we got to go
to the people and say to the people this
problem is something you've got to get
your Congress to fix and they're the
ones who are going to have to fix it yes
right here
hi I'm axel Pinto I'm a student at the
business school I wanted to ask you if
you have any call for action for the
people here assemble I think we all
pretty much agree that campaign finance
is the defining issue of this political
system so if you have any specific items
that you think people here could do yeah
so I appreciate that um and I I guess I
would you know there's lots of
particulars I could point you to again
the Citizen Equality Act project
citizens for equality is the site where
you can you can sign up and help that
but beyond particular organizations
we've got to find a way to change the
discourse about this issue right so to
make it urgent that people focus on the
need to fix this Democratic problem
first and that means really pressing
candidates that means like whenever any
candidate talks it's not just about them
saying here's what the right answer is
it's also about them explaining how
they're actually going to bring that
answer about the striking frustrating
thing to me about again the Democratic
debates is not once has any candidate
mentioned the word public funding of
Elections not once yet that is the only
solution within the horizon of the
Supreme Court changing or an amendment
of the Constitution that could make any
difference here yet they yet this issue
is not at the center and because it's
not at the center most people don't even
recognize that there is a solution which
actually they could do something if we
create a depression and just for those
who haven't been living and breathing
this it was interesting when you pointed
out that multi-member districts are not
just some innovation in some other
country they were part of the original
republic public funding of Elections is
also not foreign to the u.s. it's
something is it done in the presidency
races well right we forget that every
president between Nixon and Obama was
elected with presidential public funding
nobody benefited more from it than
Ronald Reagan who ran three national
campaigns with presidential public
funding there would have never been
Ronald Reagan had it not been
presidential public funding because in
1976 the Republican Party was not going
to fund a right-winger taking on a
sitting Republican president but the
most striking thing about that history
is when Ronald Reagan ran for
re-election he attended eight
fundraisers when Barack Obama ran for
re-election he attended two hundred and
twenty fundraisers right see just think
about the difference in the lives of
candidates between these two systems and
I think this is you know putting aside
the question of how do you run the most
difficult job in the country while
attending 225 fundraisers like you know
just I
I want some of our money back for the
salary here but the point is it's
completely distorting from the
perspective of who these people are
talking to right because 220 fund rates
raisers were not with randomly selected
Americans these are 220 fundraisers with
the tiniest slice of the 1% and four
congressional elections is there public
funding right now no no it's only been
in the presidency and it's the outside
money I gather Obama opted out of public
funding yeah Obama opted out that's what
basically ended presidential public
funding Wow
so Reagan assured it in and Obama
assured it out well Reagan took
advantage of it Nixon is the one who
caused it we have Nixon to thank for
public funding and Obama to curse fourth
straight weird times yes sir if I was a
evangelical pastor at a mega church I'd
be really excited about democracy
vouchers because all my parishioners
would have $100 to spend on campaigns if
I was the black lives matter organizers
I'd be really excited about democracy
vouchers because everyone that showed up
at my March would now have $100 to throw
a fundraiser right there for a candidate
so it seems like democracy vouchers are
a really great organizing tool to reach
out across the aisle to racial justice
groups to evangelicals to anyone who has
people but not money
why haven't we surface democracy
vouchers as a solution which seems much
more exciting than campaign finance
reform as a problem so this will also be
a test of you as a candidate can you
explain democracy vouchers and yeah
three or four tweets so democracy
vouchers is a form of public funding in
fact Seattle just passed a voucher
proposal giving everybody $100 worth of
vouchers
for city elections and so what this is
is you know when I described it in my
book I said let's take the first $50 of
everybody's taxes and everybody pays at
least $50 to the federal government
rebate it in the form of a voucher and
you use that voucher to help funds
candidates who agree to take vouchers
and small contributions and and you're
right I think it has enormous potential
to to rally people around an alternative
to the way we fund campaign
right now but it requires candidates to
be willing to talk about it and I can
tell you the first thing that
consultants say to you when you say I
want to talk about changing the way
campaigns are funded or something called
quote public funding is that you know
this will kill you
politically kill you and the truth is I
think from most of the last 50 years
that might have been the case but I
think we are finally at a place where
Americans are so deeply frustrated with
the existing system they're open to
talking about a different idea and
that's why what happened in Seattle was
so incredibly important there's a public
referendum on the idea of democracy
vouchers won overwhelmingly because
people in Seattle were so frustrated
with the big money control and just
thinking about strategically the premise
of the question was that both the left
and the right who otherwise don't agree
on anything might say hmm I might like
to play this game rather than the
chicken pecking game right the real
difference in American politics is not
between the right side and the left side
the real differences between the inside
and the outside and on the outside right
wing organizers and left wing organizers
love the idea of this kind of
people-powered funding of elections
there's a guy named Richard painter
who's on a board of a group called take
back the republic they're all right wing
organizers trying to organize public
funding of elections at this level
Richard has something he calls the
taxation without representation Act you
said this is the real Tea Party we've
got a system where people are being
taxed without being represented because
the only people represented are the
people funding campaigns so everybody
should get a two hundred dollar voucher
that they use to fund campaigns and
unless you get a voucher you shouldn't
have to pay taxes okay so so this is a
very right-wing appropriate way to talk
about the issue and they're building a
huge right-wing support for this at the
grassroots level but when you get to the
inside people on the inside it's not
that they're evil it's just they don't
have time to think about an alternative
system when they're in the middle of a
two-year election cycle and they're fine
trying to figure out how they're gonna
win the next election so that's why we
on the outside have got to build
the support the movement to allow them
to think differently about this because
otherwise they just have no time and and
they won't do it yes sir professor
thanks for taking the time and being
pretty Frank today but two questions one
I'm wondering if you think your
candidacy will spur more single-issue
referendum candidates both on the
congressional and presidential level and
if that's necessarily a good thing or if
that leads to potentially a slippery
slope I'm also wondering you had
mentioned that especially when it comes
to primaries you get more of a far-right
or far left voting population in that
I'm wondering if you think there would
be a distinct benefit from whether it
would be legislating a federal holiday
for primary or even national votes for
election days so that you can actually
have a more representative populace yes
so this this idea Bernie has pushed this
idea and the citizen equality Act
supports the idea of moving to a holiday
for voting and I think that's you know
it's obviously makes sense to equalize
the opportunity to vote so I absolutely
support that with respect to the first I
mean you know didn't be a holiday
voucher that you if you're going to take
the day off you have to go to the polls
if you have to go to Florida to vote
it's like on but you have to take a
whole vacation get a free trip to
Disneyworld but with respect to the
first issue you know technically you're
right
this was a single issue campaign in the
sense that the revolution was a single
issue revolution right I mean yeah it
was single issue but it was fundamental
to every other issue and so I don't
support the idea of you know single
issue I'm going out there the only issue
I care about is climate change even
though I think climate change are
critically I mean I I don't support that
idea but I do think that when you're at
a place where you see the system itself
is broken we have to have a way to talk
about how do we fix that system and so
you know all the time I would try to
talk about it like that and I was
instantly be put into this while you're
just a single candidate box and you know
I didn't have a skill I don't even know
how to do it to get out of that box to
get people to see that it's yes in some
sense single issue but no it's not an
insignificant issue because it's a
single
it's the only issue not because it's the
most important issue but it's because
unless you fix this issue we don't get
to solve any of yet other issues that
you're talking about so the frustrating
thing when I watch you know people
interview candidates on television like
you know Bernie would be interviewed and
people would say how are you ever gonna
pay for single-payer health care and it
would be like why is that the question
why isn't the question how would you
ever pass single health Claire when we
know Congress is owned by exactly the
interest that would never allow that to
happen how are you going to you know
what's the particular system you're
going to adopt or break up the banks
what do you mean you're never gonna
break up the banks so long as the
largest funders of congressional
campaigns come from Wall Street right
the point is the press would never focus
on the really important practical
question which was the core I thought of
this whole campaign which is we don't
have a political system that's
responsive to what the people want so we
have presidential candidates to pretend
they're running to tell them to get to
the votes from the people to tell them
what they should do without addressing
the fact that regardless of what they
want to do they're not going to do any
of it because the essential institution
in the middle is completely corrupted
and destroyed I see we have at least
nine questions pendings anything that
more words can't solve yes sir hello my
name is guy we are leaders of Wolfpack
Massachusetts as you've alluded to we at
the group which is trying to get an
article five convention to pass a 20th
amendment to get money out of politics
definitively first of all we'd like to
thank you very much for your support of
the Young Turks of Genk of of Wolf Pack
secondly I picked I like to make a
shameless plug if you'd like to do
something about it please join us we've
already got four states to call for a
convention five states halfway we're
doing graded in Massachusetts we're
going to win and we're going to change
history and and and professor Lessig is
is a supporter of us and he will be the
Godfather of our movement and third a
quiet
question I thought that might be how do
we get people to look past the glamour
of presidential politics and to actually
engage in the states where voted to wear
voter turnout it's very low and where
people don't really pay attention and
don't care that much got it got it
yeah and that's really hard but here's
the really hardest problem of the
article five convention movement which
you're right I've worked with wolfpack
gone to state legislatures I've
testified at state legislatures to get
them to pass the amendments every time
we've done this they've actually done
the proposal to call for an article five
convention but that process too has
become essentially polarized there's
like right-wing calls for a convention
balanced budgets you know ending all
sorts of things that they don't like on
the right wing and they're left wing
wing calls for a convention which is
basically the one that we've
participated in so change the way
campaigns are funded and unless we have
a way to call for a convention that is
not politically polarized it's certain
to die and this is why like if the right
succeeds in getting 34 states to call
for a convention it will be the biggest
gift to the Democratic Party's
fundraising apparatus since the Iraq war
because what the Democratic Party will
do is to say oh my gosh this Tea Party
convention is going to take away all of
our rights give us money so we can go
fight them and the same thing on the
other way around
if we actually got to 34 state then the
right would say oh my gosh these liberal
crazies are going to take over our
constitution and turn us into a
socialist republic and and a Democratic
Socialist Republic um but but again it
would be all about you know falling into
the partisan frame fundraising frame and
destroy the possibility of how we're
actually going to make progress on this
so one of the most important things wolf
Packers tried to do again and again is
to frame this in a way that's open to
issues from the right and the left being
presented and until we can get to a
place where people on the right realize
the way I think people on the Left have
that we need to make this into a cross
partisan event I fear it's going to go
across partisan that that would somehow
limit the aim of the gather
you have to make it possible to have I
think fiscal responsibility issues
that's what the right cares about and
electoral integrity issues that's what
the Left cares about both of those at
the convention if you have both of those
at the convention you can proposals from
either of them neither side should care
because you know it takes 38 states to
ratify whatever the convention does
which is a large number when you think
you know it's basically thirteen states
one house in thirteen states can block
any amendment so it's not like any crazy
right-wing amendment or any crazy
left-wing amendment is going to ever get
through so that that structure should
you know should be amenable to them but
we are so trained to think as mark
Meckler said here on the stage when he
presented this we are so trained to
think with the politics of hate where we
are focused on how we hate the other
side that the idea of working with the
other side to do something as important
as a constitutional article five
convention seems impossible almost got
it yep
they pretty much asked what I was gonna
ask which is about wolf pack your
thoughts and wolf pack so I will ask you
what can we do to push this issue
forward get money out of politics like
as citizens because obviously our
politicians don't care what we think
unless you're part of the super rich
which I know I'm not what do you yeah I
I think a thing you know we've got to
find a way to push this demand that they
talk about the solution it's not enough
to talk about the problem we got the
frame you know the billionaires have
taken over American democracy we get
that everybody gets that literally 93
percent of America will say they get
that right but the question now is what
is the solution and and we we should be
saying that to every single candidate
because the Republicans get it too right
the Republicans after Donald Trump
basically said he owned every one of
them they all are now willing to talk
about the fact that money has corrupted
this process and they and they you know
acknowledge his problem so the aunt the
question
all of us have to press every time we
can is okay what is your solution
and when typically a Democrat will say
something like this when their solution
is oh we're going to amend the
constitution and overturn citizens
united say well what is our solution in
this century right because I am all for
the movements that are talking about how
to fix the constitutional problem
through those means but we don't have
time to wait for that we've got to have
a democracy that can actually function
in 2017 that's what we need and so the
question they've got to answer is what
changes will we make now in the next
Congress that could get us a government
that could begin to govern again and
Larry what's your theory as to why this
isn't catnip to the media is it that
there's just enough issues to ask about
Isis or whatever that there's just as
boring and there's no there's just
amazing framing the media gives to this
and the media's framing is people don't
care about this issue and they will say
again and again the peak public will in
some sense say they care about money in
politics but when you ask them about the
most important issues they will never
list this okay that was true in 1994 and
in 1996 but you guys did a poll
Democratic voters they asked if the next
president could do just one thing what
should that one thing be and by far over
any other issue the one thing was fixing
the corrupted way we fund campaigns this
issue is now right at the very top but
nobody you know there's nobody to
discipline the media about this to get
them to sort of recognize the salience
of this so they continue to frame it in
a way that makes this issue invisible
and and you know that again I think was
part of the opportunity that I wanted to
have the chance to the debate to do to
press this so that you could begin to
get the recognition in the public that
would get people to do something about
it but obviously that didn't happen yes
sir yeah Tom so both the right and the
left do agree that this is a big issue
so why is it that it's become partisan
and how do we change that it's become
partisan because everything is partisan
you know so in 2014 Harry Reid needed to
raise a bunch of money for the
Democrats so what did he do in August
early September he brought to the floor
of the United States Senate a proposal
to amend the Constitution to overturn
Citizens United okay so here was a
amendment to the Constitution designed
to address the problem of money in
politics that was brought to the floor
of the Senate to make it easier to raise
money for democratic politics
recognizing that doing that would have
zero chance of attracting any Republican
support for a bill that requires
two-thirds of the Senate to have any
chance of passing so why was he doing it
well he was doing it because it advanced
the interest of the Democratic Party
does advancing the interest of
Democratic Party make it more likely
that we will win on this issue No so the
problem is that the the interests in
this partisan scheme are not necessarily
consistent with us winning on this
interest which is why I think we've got
to find a way to build a kind of citizen
political movement citizen politicians
people who are not politicians not
wannabe politicians people on the
outside who are demanding this kind of
change because people on the inside
live according to a different economy
and the economy is just what benefits
partisan interests here and that's
making it impossible for us to make
progress would you consider a third
party run you know the problem in
America today is it's practically
impossible to imagine a third party run
on the rules the debate commission have
said for being in the general election
debate are so restrictive that even Ross
Perot could not qualify to be you know
wouldn't have qualified in the polls you
have to be 15 percent in the polls
before they'll allow you to be in the
debate and of course the 15 percent is
measured just before the debate which
means that nobody has any incentive to
you know support a candidate when you've
got to begin to support a candidate like
that which would be now because the
chance of getting to 15 percent before
that debate just seems so unlikely so um
you know this is a consequence again of
the Democrats and Republicans working
together to basically mean that they own
field and so that makes it really
incredibly hard to imagine doing
something like that but you know I think
I and many people here are gonna do
whatever the hell it takes right
whatever it takes whatever crazy
intervention is possible to force this
issue and to make this change and you
know we'll see what what seems possible
yep yes professor Lessig you observed
that a large part of the American public
is not represented because if you're a
Republican or you know represented by a
Democratic Congress person you know your
representative doesn't much care about
you I I think that's inaccurate or maybe
an incomplete observation because I find
that as a Democrat in a
represented by a democratic
representative my representative doesn't
care about me either
[Applause]
always nice to find a silver lining I
mean what I've observed over the years
is that at election time if I happen to
be a baby they'll kiss me if I you know
they may want to shake my hand and have
about a three word conversation with me
but if I want to have a substantive
substantive discussion with them when
they want my vote they're too busy if
it's not when they want my vote I get
shunted off to some aide who's probably
an underpaid intern recently either high
school or college you know or a college
student who never passes you know my
comments on to the representative so as
an American citizen my thoughts on
anything don't count for anything yeah
you know what you're expressing and what
the applause expresses is this deep
recognition acknowledgement we all seem
to have about the flaw the failure of
this democracy right um some people feel
it more than others the first campaign
stopped that I did was at Ferguson
Missouri and you know the opportunity to
spend three hours in the basement with
the people who had organized the protest
after the Ferguson tragedy was three
hours experiencing a level of disconnect
with our political system a thousand
miles greater than anything you are
describing right so this is the natural
state of America's democracy right now
people not represented and so you might
be right the Democrats are not
represented just like Republicans are
not represented regardless of the city
but this is our feeling now we could
give up to say this is just democracy it
doesn't work and in fact I've been in at
events where very rich people say we
ought to give up we ought to just forget
the idea of democracy do what China does
kind of have technocratic solutions to
every problem
um but I think what we ought to do is to
try represented a democracy for once
we've not yet tried it you know we've
never tried it really we've never
included people equally really
african-americans women the poor but if
we actually tried it and embraced the
idea of equality inside of our political
system um I would I want to see if in 50
years after that happens we have a
better feeling about the way democracy
works and so so I you know one last shot
let's try once for a really
representative democracy and see what we
can get from it and if it doesn't work
okay then we can think about you know
the internet or something like that as
well I just like to say I applaud you
for trying to get us from here to there
thank you we are we are and we're just
beginning from here today that's right
so we don't have a whole lot of time
left and I want to make sure that the
few who have filtered out didn't eat all
the food so I'd like to take the the
three here and the one here maybe and
then save the rest for when we adjourn
yes sir it's an honor to be here thank
you for everything that you have done
continue to do Congress is corrupt
incompetent lots of words we could use
what is the solution Belgium has an
interesting idea they are going to be
selecting from the citizenry people to
be in their Senate I think that's a
brilliant idea
the ancient Greeks did it sortition I
don't see why we couldn't do it as a
stepping stone from here to there
because obviously that's not going to
happen overnight and as something that
might potentially you know give you -
you know for an independent run a
citizen Senate what do you think so he
was actually talking about sortition
which well but leads to a citizen's
assembly you've done these all over it's
two-thirds citizens one-third elected so
I love the idea in principle and I want
to try it right away through something
like it's called deliberative polls
which Jim fish can have described and I
would love to see one can
tomorrow randomly selecting 500 people
from around the country to focus on what
constitutional changes we should bring
about to deal with the problems of
America's democracy tomorrow
and and I think you would see out of
that process actually ordinary citizens
are pretty good at figuring out what the
right answer is when given the right
information and an opportunity to talk
about it and fair in representative way
so I'm all for this kind of experiment
and if we did it repeatedly I think
there would be more confidence to
turning more of the government over to
effectively a better jury system than
the jury system which can fix people and
sends them to jail yes I'm sorry we got
to keep it moving yes oh good evening
Sheldon Fisher I'm an alumnus when I
heard of your candidacy it kind of made
me feel good I heard you raised about a
million bucks and I believe that made
you feel pretty good so if you don't
mind if I refer you as dr. feelgood and
I mean that most respectfully in this
country and perhaps throughout this
world there's very little you can do in
a profession without having taken an
exam of some sort you can't get a
driver's license you can't practice
medicine and certainly not law you see
my point or Accountancy I would advocate
sir if one day you could become
president of these United States that I
could shake your hand as you took the
year off of office at the United States
Congress and in your inaugural address
you suggested that there needed to be a
comprehensive exam the dealt with War
nuclear another the history and
geography of the world the cultures of
the world and that anyone who dares to
think they can be president needs to
prove to the people that he has some or
she has some real sense in their head
like we've all had to prove to get
through our various exams throughout
life because other than wearing a suit
really well I don't see that there's
much in the way of real
pre-qualifications if you will to become
president of the United States thank you
thank you so what he's describing is
supposed to be called the campaign
process right has to be called that's
the vetting yeah supposed to be called
as the media that's what the media is
supposed to do and if the media did its
job we would have that comprehensive
exam process as people would have to
demonstrate that they had some death now
what scares me is that even where you do
see some efforts by the media to measure
whether people have any understanding of
certain pretty critical issues it's not
clear the public's reacting to that
right so the public doesn't seem to care
much about the fact that Donald Trump
doesn't know [ __ ] about what he's
talking about doesn't care about that
crap
so and Larry were you prepared if you
had made it into the debates as each
question was asked Isis this health care
that with each of your answers be look
the first thing we have to do is fix
campaign finance reform where would you
give substance of answers on each of
those no every one of these issues that
would have I would give a subset of
answer i sat down and wrote out the
policy papers that included all of these
issues but the obvious point is to weigh
all of those issues tie back to this
issue of the money so it's make the
right answer clear and to show why the
right answer is not an answer we can get
yeah so we solve this problem of the
corrupting influence of money first got
it let's take the last two here that I
mentioned and then wrap up thank you
thank you for running for president I
hope that many follow in your steps it's
or my impression of what happens here
campaign is that but you are denied
access by the polling companies and by
the party and not not only were you
denied access but also seeming very
arbitrarily and it seems to me that
there was a point in the campaign
between sort of when you knew that it
wasn't gonna move forward but before you
dropped out but you know you could have
sued someone like you know sued someone
not to help yourself but to help the
next person American of remedies
we are at the law school after all did
you think about suing in fact a lawyer
called me and said I'll sue and you know
it's just not the nature of the problem
in my view it's not I you know I'm a law
professor I love the law I love lawyers
I love the idea of making justice work
but I want to make democracy work so the
idea that you know you would go and
imagine a court ordering the Democratic
Party to do something is just not the
way I'd want to win same idea on
demanding equal time under some of the
rusty communications laws for you know
SNL gives time to Hillary don't you get
time to yeah well of course that
strategy was earlier than at the point
he was talking about that strategy was
part of the process of trying to get
enough attention to get to the 1% in the
polls yes but but so you're right
there might be a legal action and it
you're right it might be the right thing
for someone to do but it wasn't the
thing that I wanted to do I wanted to
win I wanted to make this fight it might
fight about the democratic process and
and you know the fights not over we'll
see you know we'll see where this goes
last question yes all right thank you my
name is Jasper burns I'm a student at
Boston University a lot of what you've
been focusing on is on the federal level
and I was just wondering if there's
anything that should or could happen on
the state of local level yeah so the
only exciting stuff is happening at the
state or local level right now I'm so
Seattle passed vouchers Maine has a
referendum to reinforce their public
funding of Elections Connecticut
Democrats toyed with the idea of
removing their public funding proposal
and within two days the up drawer of the
outrage of that idea forced them to back
down from it we had victories in
Tallahassee in the last election where
they passed an anti-corruption statute
all of this is happening to local level
I think much more effectively than at
the federal level um but here's the
concern I have at the local level and I
support these movements 100% but we have
to wreck
guys the problem might be different in
Vermont from in Congress right and and
the answers might be different for
Vermont versus Congress I mean Vermont I
mean Congress is like New York maybe or
like Illinois um and so you know I'd be
happy to generalize there but if we
build a movement that focus is just at
the local level and we solve the local
problems I fear people won't see how
radically different and harder the
federal problem is so what I think we
need to do is to work on all of these at
the same time we got to be pushing at
the federal level and at the state level
and at the local level but rallying
around this idea that we deserve a
democracy responsive to us equally
that's the idea that should unite all of
these and as we fight for that and we
build this recognition outside of the
political Beltway the beltway of
Washington I begin I believe we begin to
have the power to to actually win so
that's fantastic but it's not enough and
obviously nothing we've been is enough
that we've done so far is enough but um
but I you know the truth is even though
this was a very difficult campaign it
was actually it was the best of times
and the worst of times right so cable
news must reverse the phone's right yeah
that's right
it's cable news was the worst of times
that was that was not an experience to
be loved and but the experience of
talking to voters experiences like this
experience of like talking to groups of
10 people or in an old folks home that
is the most rewarding experience I think
I've ever had because the deep genuine
passion people have about getting a
democracy they can respect or feels is
responsive to them to follow up on that
other question is is is really
empowering it as it is it convinces me
we could win this issue you know we did
a poll we found 96% of Americans believe
it important to reduce the influence of
money in politics 91 percent don't think
it's possible that's the politics of
resignation
but the politics of resignation gives
you a perfect strategy for winning which
is to a campaign of resignation that's
right the resignation campaign yeah okay
that wasn't the perfect campaign but the
point is it's still in the perfect
direction of like how do we thaw that
resignation because once we do then I
think we have a chance a real chance of
winning so that's why it's an amazing
bookend of sort of hope at the end is
the blood pools around Jon Snow but
spoiler alert sorry but we framed this
as lessons learned and if dr. who showed
up and took you back to July of 2015
what if anything would you do
differently yeah you're gonna have to
wait for that I don't know it's I'm too
close too close I mean I you know I am
so grateful for the opportunity and
given that the gamble was could we get
into the debates you know we qualified
so that gamble was worth it didn't turn
out to get us into the debates all right
fine but still the gamble was worth it
and costly but worth it and and you know
one more one more strategy on the way to
figuring the one strategy that will
finally make it so we win well our
notion of a citizen stepping forward to
say hat in the ring let's give this a go
that is an inspirational notion that you
rarely see coming from people
particularly people who frankly are well
ensconced within the elite I am NOT
surmising about your bank account but
certainly as far as the level of success
you have attained in the world and to be
willing to step forward and do it is
quite extraordinary and I'm trying to
think of any other example in which that
has happened can you think of one
let's think of that later on that
somewhat contemplative notes please join
me in thanking Larry Lessig
[Applause]
[Music]
sure be happy to
thank you hi I'm from China
nice to meet you yeah the group your
rights of free culture is the first book
I recommended for each group yeah I'm
doing my international property master
degree in China now and I thank you so
much for all the book I really
appreciate you in the our recommended
reading list for our law school I
appreciate very much translating your
books free culture in China in Chinese
because I think the current version has
a really big incorrect mixtape you
change the title free into the free of
charge operator well that's terrible
yeah well thank you for doing that
yeah send me something about that when
you're done
great thank you nice to meet you
connecting Millennials I news related
stories of personal experience also a
non-profit for the secondary schools of
course about your but also a quick
question about a person maybe has the
same problem Caucasus worse what
pressure could be back to their entrance
other pro media outlets I just have to
change the way we communicate I mean you
know it just happened it's just we're in
the middle of this transition now to
figure out a new way to commute it but
you're right the media is just
exacerbates an email yep hi thank you
met Mike peacocks is another friend huh
and I asked American people just don't
understand how art a truly antiquated
our electoral colleges yeah and that
that's really at the end of the day well
that's one prophecy and I would be all
in favor of fixing that problem but I'm
fixing that problem alone you know won't
fix there you have two minutes before we
have to extract okay thank you good all
right
thank you thanks very much thought to
how the internet might be mobilized more
to this process you know tons yeah you
know this is the hardest thing yeah
getting YouTube productions like I am
Donald Trump's worst nightmare we're
getting musicians to sing all of its
people's willingness you're eager this
is all tied to the question whether they
think you have any shot and so that was
you know our plan was to get into
debates to be able to establish that
there was some shot some reasonable
chance to do something and if we did
there then I think you know all of us
would be impossible until that point it
was a complete longshot big one for me
if we do they have a convention of state
bill vodka you know what if they change
the rules to ratification they can't
this is a point that is confused by how
many people article five convention has
no power to do anything other than to
propose amendments the original
Constitutional Convention that gave us
our constitution was a Constitutional
Convention which means it was not
constrained by anything right even the
Articles afetr no no it wasn't called
pursuant to the Articles of
Confederation it was a constitutional
convention so it's a completely
different animal all that article 5
convince you can do is to propose ideas
which once they're proposed have to be
ratified by three-quarters in States so
I don't think is that part is not open
to open any by the article vacuum is
perfect thank you
I just want a picture okay great
thank you very much it's your book thank
you for you or great you'll be famous
you are thank you very much thank you I
have no one out here then I want to help
out on the spring
okay I'd get as many 1lc I can't no so
yeah they're gonna be action sir yes
yeah yeah note and great yeah and I'm
gonna come to April March yes okay great
thank you so much for all your different
your girl thanks I came all the way from
China and in my country many people
knows exactly what happens here like the
crack of the crop raishin compress
Congress like the fund raisers affecting
the but many people back at home they
think that this might be dictatorship
versus democracy dictatorship finally
wings like it does not work for a
democracy so how you can respond to them
like for those questions hopeful for
those ideas well I think that if we had
a representative democracy that would be
dictatorship easily you know so I think
all we have to do is we have to fight
together representative democracy and
that's what this movement is about like
how do you get us back get us to a place
where you don't have such extraordinary
power being exercised by such a tiny
tiny number of people and and that's
what representative democracy is about
okay okay sure
thanks thanks
hi thanks your question Thank You doc I
just wanted to get it sure okay you like
it sweet a selfie great thanks thanks
brother and I are big fans
oh thank you thanks for coming hi hi I'm
Trever I'm a freshman at the college and
I just wanted to thank you for running
and giving you a little bit of faith in
the process
Thank You pictures of course she's very
much hey let me say thank you should
finish it out there and and help them
tell them you realize what what's
important to me in the future of the
country sure does thank you thanks very
much thanks today inspiring and have two
books one for me okay so actually what's
your first name
and this is for the students of years
fear three years ago who are also
commercial ones Philippine and our class
because I'm Philip and to H by L I do
yeah